[Musique]
vu que mon député de finition pour le
plus
sa fille le toit
un dealer un revendeur arrêté c'est
aussitôt pour les drogués une source
d'héroïne qui se tarit alors les toxicos
courte à la recherche d'un autre
fournisseur
il parcourt la ville il cherche avec au
ventre les premières crampes qui annonce
le manque
leurs corps leurs organismes réclament
la dose pour la voir il se donnerait au
diable
tulle à l'affût ouais
la cote de m
peut-être c'est bon
je suis venu chercher
il sait pas
elodie leur habituel par un petit trait
mais je vous regarde et sur quelle
claque
que tu veux tu m'intéresses
je
muller 660 ce film peu d'herbe et tu me
complète mesnil pour on est un peu
chacun c'est pas toi qui l'avais
ouais non merci encore
ce type est un détaillant en héroïne un
épicier de la défense en quelque sorte
il stocke la poudre lapèze la répartie
en petits sachets puis l'avant est ce
que vous êtes en train de faire des
chansons de michael 4 grammes d'héroïne
pour cameron de nicole serge achète
quatre grammes de c'est quelqu'un que
j'ai vu grand pour la revente
les g j'ai peut-être eu vent de 5
grammes les trois autres quand je les
gardais pour moi pour ma consommation
personnelle
donc même en revendant les 500 grammes
toutefois ça me ramène l'argent que j'ai
dépensé à l'achat j'ai trop g qui me
reste à moi et ma consommation et
gratuit ils ont que la tige vendait tout
ça si je vendais mes 8 g là il y aurait
dix mille francs 1 million il ya le
quart de gramme saison 250 francs le
demi gramme 500 francs et le g mille
francs comme nous l'avons n'est pas pire
parce que déjà c'est pas tellement mon
intérêt puis disons qu'il ya
certainement beaucoup d'accidents si
toutefois je la vends des plus hauts
parce qu'ils les gens sont paris sont
invités à acheter une
une droite dure on allait couper plus ou
moins coupé bon ils ont l'habitude de
s'envoyer une certaine dose si elle
mettant un gars qui se fait dans son
fixe il met
ans accueillir m 1,10 g si je lui
donnais un est grand pur de celle là qui
se mettant la cuillère pour son fixe il
ferait une overdose assuré donc ça se
passe les ventes de ses espaces bombe
dans la rue j'ai un point de chute
les gars qui va chez savent où me
trouver je vends à peu près toujours aux
mêmes personnes
j'ai jamais vendu en a qui arrivent du
mont-blanc fair a fixé la première fois
on respecte la jugeant pas comment vous
faites pour avoir mon client la voix
c'est à dire les nouveaux clients sont
emmenés par déjà les bacs qui je vend
habituellement une personne que je
connais pas je vends pas à part si c'est
une personne nouvelle qui accompagné par
quelqu'un que je connais déjà et qui
j'ai l'habitude de vendre
d'ailleurs aucun problème à cette
personne juin
est-ce que vous avez la poule sur
mouscron vous allez assez bonnes dans
les jambes et surtout sa mission vous ne
parlez jamais son nom ça se passe
pourquoi ce concept la boule un goûter
non là secret pouvoir récupérer son
couteau
et elle vient de 7 contre ça c'est de la
française la française c'est à dire
c'est à dire je pense que sa seule mini
ciel vient certainement de de marseille
ou l'italie enfin c'est pas une poudre
qui est faite au moyen-orient ni en asie
elle était en possession de toute
manière quand je vais descendre
certainement tout à l'heure pour vendre
je prendrais pas tout ça sur moi je vais
prendre un maximum de grave mais ces
deux grammes là je les laisserais dans
le même paquet parce que si jamais de
chez moi à mon point de chute si
toutefois je me faisais arrêter soit par
les policiers piste par la brigade des
stupéfiants je peux faire passer ce
paquet de 2 grammes pour la consommation
personnelle
si j'ai plusieurs petits paquets sur moi
le deal est tout de suite prouvé donc je
tombe se pose aucun problème
nous fait la démonstration du snif
absolument pas je vous fais pas une
illustration du good food is que gm veut
ce revendeur la firme de l'héroïne est
actuellement raffiné en france mais bien
davantage encore en italie la france
depuis l'époque de la french connection
et dans ce domaine une nation en pointe
si l'on peut dire elle possède les
meilleurs chimiste ses techniciens liés
au milieu du grand banditisme qui savent
le mieux
raffiné la morphine base pour la
transformer en héroïnes essais chimiste
français travaillent en thaïlande en
italie au proche orient
ils sont aux commandes des laboratoires
clandestins qui fournissent les dealers
c'est un bon plan et ça c'est un super
fort ouais j'aimerais de kwaga temps
jadis libanaise
[Musique]
apprends à 2 heures d'appels idi amin
allez bonne nuit bien arrosée avait très
bonne tu vois c'est hyper un que j'ai
trouvé une concert c'est bon on peut
goûter
j'y reviens là tu me lâches est clair à
90 85 des mois du fait 5 à 65 soit 7 et
300 sacs gerber
sur les boire un coup
a bordeaux on va bien mais je descends
je bois un verre avec vous je défends
tu bravo à toi
[Musique]
continuez tout droit
je fais travailler matière grise pour
trop de la pauvreté
[Musique]
de thaïlande de turquie depuis peu du
liban aussi arrive la poudre qui
aussitôt s'infiltre se répand sous nos
yeux aveugles dans un monde qui côtoie
le nôtre qui s'y met elle même et qui
est pourtant tout autre le monde des
défoncer des héroïnomanes un monde qui a
ses règles et ses mots ses rythmes ses
explosions de plaisir c'est bref
jouissance et puis cette descente
inéluctable
lorsque le besoin et le manque
l'emportent mais non mais ce que je
nomme je t'ai dit je t'ai donné je pense
pas jamais jamais moi non mais magique
toi j'avance jeu il ya cinquante mètres
qui veulent que je le reconnais qu'il
est question
les gens étaient très mal à l'aise je
suis des crampes de tous les côtés crois
tu es mal dans ta peau tu étais vraiment
qu'elle était isolé tu te sens tu te
sens tout seul son tout seul tu es
vraiment même s'il ya du monde autour de
toi tu es poussins tu n'arrives pas à
entrer en communication avec les gens
que tu vas pas tu vas pasky tu mens donc
tu la pente était paraître les gens
n'étaient pas là commencé comme tout le
monde commence par le shit et puis ont
battu tous deux trois ans et puis ça
fait six ans vraiment que je touche à la
chan vraiment vraiment touché à la gamme
ajouté et depuis trois 3 4 ans et
intensive que cet appel intensif cv
reçus tous les jours
les jours que l'afo faut de la passion
et par n'importe quel moyen peut
attaquer un dealer 20 n'importe quoi
apprends le volley volley avant de
l'argent en cassant le patient des
portes à n'importe quoi tout tout est
bon écoutez bon du moment d'arriver à
voir quelque chose dans les veines tu te
prostitueraient aussi en tant que
gagnent mais si j'étais une femme et je
le ferai sûrement
c'est une c'est une chose qui m'a
vraiment qui m'a vraiment raté la tête
si j'étais une femme est ce que je me
prostitue grand monsieur à peu près sûr
que
les toxicomanes prostituées il en existe
dans toutes les villes chez nous des
femmes des hommes des travestis dont on
ne sait plus s'ils ont fini par vendre
leur corps pour se procurer l'argent de
leurs drogues ou si au contraire il se
défend ce pour mieux supporter la rue le
trottoir le tapa les passes
je pars
se régale ce pas vous ni avec moi enfin
tout vient va être chaud vraiment pas
la série
j'ai commencé en gigolo communisme en
travaux
et la cam est venue après et alors avec
un peu de calme quand tu es pas speed
dating
colossal tous a bel et bien en train de
faire le client sans savoir qui est qui
elle donne aux halles commente le
premier le dos de nos alliés des
docteurs qui sont plus ou moins
[Musique]
contre une judith majorer la visite qui
est de 60 euros le pass à 353 ils te
font de bons toxines
testez pétillant
[Rires]
mon combat est ailleurs que cela fait du
matin au soir
les moments forts de la journée son
suffixe de l'injection d'héroïne en
n'importe quel endroit
cette fille à la démarche cotonneuse et
ce garçon qui va la suivre dans un
instant viennent de se piquer dans les
toilettes de ce bar marseillais du
patron simple client
chacun le sait
[Musique]
ce dimanche mais dans sa forme à la
surface
[Musique]
et quand l'héroïne est trop cher ou trop
rares les toxicomanes lorgne vers les
armoires les pharmacies il repère à
force ils savent où sont enfermés les
produits interdits
la morphine les speed les neuroleptiques
tous ces comprimés qui permettent de
voyager dans la tête lorsque la poudre
manque de drogués parce que drogués ils
deviennent casseurs
vous n'avez pas de faille des gens
n'avaient pas de feuilles qui pue on a
goûté à la vie à la côte est ou peut -
on avoue on a fait des passes comme ça
pas mal mais la coupe c'est pas c'est
quoi la vie pharmacie passé défendant
son web comme n importe quoi c était
pour une trentaine je vais peut-être
causé une vingtaine plus on en avait on
en voulait chapeau qui nous a manqué
nous on a vous d autres puits
c'est facile comme ça on était trois à
la casse dans la bagnole
puis on rentre à 2 comment la france à
bas s'est acharné des serrures en place
et rod a pu montrer ce qu'il nous
fallait se fait choper un cross a plutôt
donné à fond
on allait faire un cross fonctions avec
nous avait vus tout d'un ciné-club
annuel il se fait arrêter
c'est bon
la nuit les jeunes qui sortent de leur
trou ils sont seuls ils traînent on
galère du style chez john key et doxique
au qui se piquent le mot solidarité
n'existe pas chacun pour soi pour
s'adopte faubourg montmartre nous avons
rencontré fakty
qui fait rien h 30
j'étais à l'air
je cache vol à l'étalagé je fais ma part
je
pour la carte
pour la came pour manger pour pour vivre
quoi c'est surtout pour la can
lance la chasse est fixée par jour t'as
pas l'impression que tu t'y es en train
de te suicider si je sais chanter
des grades tactile je le sais mais
si on veut pas nous en veut pas de moi
alors je préfère en finir comme ça et je
me devais gratuite à petit c'est tout
qui veut pas de toi
tout le monde ni ma famille ni personne
personne veut de moi j'ai pas d'amis je
suis tout seul je suis chez pearson
une heure plus tard nous avons retrouvé
fatigue des fonds s'est effondré sur un
banc sa tête tituber les passants
indifférents ne lui sautaient pas le
moindre regard
fatigue une clocharde déjà
et à marseille nous avons rencontré le
double de faty lise prisonnière comme
elle de la drogue même mot même
désespoir
et comme une tortue fixe dit quand
j'avais 17 ans que je peux penser comme
vous se coucher que je pense que c'est
pas tellement intéressant c'est m'a
appris à ne jamais manquer psychologique
fait au moins avant je prenais pas je
prenais pas trop d'héroïne je prenais
sur peut surtout du spin des trucs comme
ça
l'acide aussi c'est vachement
intéressant mais après ça s'est tenue un
peu tu rentres en avait une espèce de
phases un peu dépressive rapport
[Musique]
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça la
descente après comme la plupart des gens
que je connais j'ai des choses plus ou
moins bon mais c'est difficile de faim
il faut vraiment avoir une volonté de
fer
c'est comme si tu veux je prends un
exemple peu stupide mais c'est comme ça
arrêter de fumer avec des gens qui je
suis monté en doute pas c'est vachement
plus difficile pour
tous le disent tous veulent sortir du
milieu de la défonce pour décrocher
briser ce cercle magique et démoniaque
mais dans leur monde qui tourne en rond
et toxico reprenne en main celui qui
tente d'en sortir prosélyte pour ne pas
être seul en enfer
[Musique]
on est huit jours
non penses tu des pôles dont la relation
4 comment allez c'est pas grâce par lé
bouger la pompe
allez tout neuf et boucher se dit
cependant c'est tout neuf chez les
mythes d'encre
je vois des redifs c'est ennuyeux
remporté 12 de ses 17 ans
j'ai par l'ugta pas envie de sauter venu
en appui de passer de l'autre côté et
envie de voir autre chose et puis c'est
une solution
c'est assez facile c'est un pétard tutu
pour titi va vous tuer vous bon après
une forte demande et que lens mais c'est
pas pour ça pue tu change carrément pas
ce que tu peux faire ce que je cherche
toujours avec ou sans à dos bon c'est
une période où on sait tout le temps les
pantoufles
ça dépend de ce que tu vas faire avec
rose et une salade toujours en recherche
toujours sinon show triple faire
continué à shooter plutôt peur de le
chercher
j'essaie de bosser et puis j'ai donc
assez de pluie pendant des années à me
dire tiens alors que je fasse à des
chats ça on va papa alors pendant ce
mandat c'est ça tu végète
j'ai tout en même que tu prête pas
dessus quand tu te fais un shoot primé
jette toi quand tu t'en fais pendant
quinze jours des shoots pas venir que
pendant quinze jours piégés
les gens qui sont en demande dans le
monde de la poudre sont les dégâts ont
eu envie de vivre comme ça autant dire
autrement quoi c'est pas vrai quoi c'est
bon je pense quelque chose très
intéressante que ça ait détruit le plus
intéressant mais vas-y pour les attraper
et retient une ou deux c'est vachement
plus facile ccg pas fait une recherche
sur la cité savons rien à part la dureté
des trucs c'est pas bon c'est beaucoup
plus facile de ce que tu parles 70% si
t'es dans la merde c'est pas faux mais
c'est pour ça je n'aurais on perd son
papa
si je m'en prends les gens sont cons les
gens sont cons titan comptes pour leurs
conneries mais la société peut-être pas
trop lui en maître sur le monde
c'est vrai c'est vrai que sa mère
d'école votre problème mais le problème
et qui boit ou qui se défoncer
c'est à la base à la base pourquoi la
presse parce qu'à la base site en est
arrivé là c'est qu'il ya forcément une
connerie qui sont à ses pieds parfois
ajouté j'avais envie d'y goûter pour
voir ce que ça faisait c'était parce que
j'étais mal dans ma tête j'ai fait tous
travaillera jamais ça m'est arrivé de
travailler sans fausse évidemment tmc en
bouleau qui plaît pas
c'est vous qui me plaisait pas si
certains points
[Musique]
tu t'es non seulement présenter ce
qu'ils ont
si longtemps a terminé ton temps
[Musique]
peut-être seulement on attendait tu le
printemps
[Musique]
n'est ce pas
ronald à
[Musique]
le pic que tu as laissé ne sera jamais
comblé
[Musique]
possible d'oublier cette blessure aux
côtes et
[Musique]
si je ne vais jamais sur ta tombe
pleurer
si jeunes et déjà mais mais
voser un bouquet
que je sais où du
ce corps enterrés
[Musique]
araji
orange
[Musique]
à paris la brigade des stupéfiants
interpelle les contrôles 6000
toxicomanes chaque année 50 par jour
dans la moitié sont des héroïnomanes qui
se livre aussi au trafic
en 1975 les usagers revendeurs étaient
dix fois moins nombreuses mais la police
est débordée réellement incapable de
stopper l'arrivée et la distribution de
la poudre impossible d'arrêter la marche
de temps de fourmies les policiers
réclament comme toujours plus de moyens
et voudrait que la justice applique des
peines plus forte des peines dissuasives
l'ombre de bangkok plaindre et elle sur
la france que faire le mal grandi le
mâle s'accroît en 1975 à paris 22 jeunes
toxicomanes sont morts d'un abus de
drogues en 1981 on comptait 64 décès par
overdose
et cette année en neuf mois ce chiffre
est déjà dépassée banalisation de la
drogue
personne n'est protégé fini les
sanctuaires elle est partout la cam
aujourd'hui
les enfants eux aussi ont prouvé leur
drogue il s'envole avec leurs mobylettes
et en achetant des produits bon marché
en vente libre
il détourne de leur usage eau écarlate
trichloréthylène cole is nice il renifle
les enfants du quart monde surtout ceux
là sont déjà à 10 ans entré dans le
tunnel de la drogue comme ici dans une
hlm de marseille
l'arrivée
[Musique]
serge wellens jamais je me sers nous
prendre la corde d'entamer parce que
c'est l'odeur qui est bonne ça fait
tourner la tête ça sans comprendre la
cause wen a qui disent ça arrange ou le
symbole ça sent à peu près deux ans
comme falla col de 4 - montupet joue pas
je te protégerai la principale sur cinq
y aller nicher à l'oeil mavericks
ça va c'est pas été mais salle
qu'est ce qui vous a initié à la colle
cellule de 200 radios et avait donné
comme ça ils prenaient dans la com et
moi j mais je fais c'est quoi ça
vraiment du goût et j'ai goûté je veux
que s'arrête at-elle tourné tout près il
ya trois ans de ça après suis venu à
marseille en vacances sont venus à
marseille je leur ai montré leur faudra
lui faire ça il a pu souffrir je sais je
sais pas mais je ne crois pas qu'on le
croit mais on continue on va s'arrêter
non ces enfants ne sont pas près de
s'arrêter
aujourd'hui la colle demain la seringue
l'éguille comme ces deux jeunes leurs
aînés de quelques années à peine qui se
fixe tout à côté et sans voix dans les
veines leur dose de rêve au milieu des
ordures
je veux jouer
quartier de belleville à paris même en
plein jour maintenant le manège des
vendeurs et des acheteurs ne s'arrête
plus le phénomène a pris autant
d'importance que les échanges sont à
peine discret
posté au coin d'une rue il attend sans
contact
caméra cachée du premier étage d'un
immeuble
nous avons filmé un deal une transaction
le toxicomane s'adresse à un premier
homme celui-ci le quitte pour aller
chercher un second intermédiaire il
vient il n'a pas la drogue mais prend la
commande est l'argent il part alors
chercher la poudre puis la ramène
les changes se fait ensuite de la main à
la main
dans ce monde des drogués celui qui
tient la poudre tient le pouvoir
celui qui cherche la poudre n'est qu'un
pion un pantin manipulable et corvéables
à merci
il y avait un copain à côté il y avait
ce qu'on a trouvé un lancement cascadeur
qui fournissait un prix convenable
d'abonnement chili et comme il s'en
sortait plus il m'a présenté
oui c'était
c'est un petit jamais travaillé je
présume
d'expédients pour lui c'était au même
titre il aurait pu vent
[Musique]
l'important c'était un moyen
son travail est très bons rapports
puis après ça s'est un peu détériorée au
moment où je n'ai su pu retrouver les
si j'étais de plus en plus dépendants de
plus dont on était 2 avec matt m
oui et on n'arrivait plus un
s'en sortir
attends tu t'es obligé de faire des
montages
faire avancer de l'argent
c'est à dire vingt neuf sont produits
avant qu'il me les romains finalement il
y a que comme ça où j'arrive à m'en
sortir
ils savaient très bien par son
expérience qui lève qu'avant paroles
signifient les 100 grammes d'un coup je
serai d'une semaine après complètement
accroché puissances en leurs ventes
on nous donnait 10 grammes en se disant
pour se vendre à bord il sera obligé de
vendre et il essayait de me tenir comme
ça
est ce que tu penses au mec que tu as
fait plonger en mon nom et qui était pas
accrocheur c'est une question difficile
parce que c'est facile de dire non j'ai
ma conscience pour moi
après si on me l'a fait plus les mecs
ils savaient ce qu'il faisait plus
banques ça c'est sûr que sur le moment
on n'y fait pas attention
sur le moment ce qui compte c'est ce sa
petite personne mais intérieurement en
l'occurrence été pensés comme des
pensées plus importants moyens je vais y
arriver à voler de l'argent mais par an
moi j'en suis là pourquoi parce qu'on me
l'a fait je m'aperçois que je fais la
même chose c'est comme
sur une table de ping pong négatif
envoyé la balle et moi je fais passer le
témoin que je faut pas se leurrer de la
drogue y en a partout
il y en a
n'importe quel petit village font de
l'art de si on a si on veut prouver
encore hélène toxicomane au chant elle
vit à livinhac du côté de toulouse
elle aussi a galéré quittant ses parents
paysans montant à la ville zone en
rencontrant dans le béton l'héroïne
et puis elle est revenue au pays avec
quelques cernes de plus quelques kilos
de moi et surtout l'indispensable besoin
de la dose
la source [ __ ] un peu hâlé
[Applaudissements]
dans ce village c'était c'était bien il
ya l'année dernière c'était même forte
c'était bien parce que on était
pratiquement à cinq minutes nous ont
déçus des autres et on va fixer tous y
en avait un circuit à paris il
descendait ici ou alors à toulouse
toujours eu de la pole pendant un an
et puis il y avait des gens qui vivaient
chez moi qui était défoncée aussi et
alors c'est qu'on en avait tous les
jours tous les jours dès le matin vont
déjeuner je conçois
hélène cherche à s'en sortir et bien sûr
dans ce village
elle se retrouve encore plus seul
bon maintenant puis-je ouvrira une
boutique tu vois une toute petite
boutique depuis deux mois
des fois le matin je me dis mais qu'est
ce que tu fous là tu vois qu'est ce que
tu fous là tu sais bien que les gens et
viendront pas chez toi
enfin j'essaye donc j'essaye j'essaye de
tenir le coup et je pense que c'est à
cause de la com
ah ouais c'est sûr mais c'est sur moi
c'est sûr vu qu'en plus je suis en face
la pharmaco et que le mec il m'a viré tu
vois on m'a viré parce que je venais
trouve souvent lui demander des comptes
parce qu ils savent que je suis une came
mais ils se disent que que ça me
concerne disent que c'est ma peau que
qu'ils en ont rien à [ __ ] à partir du
moment où je touche pas à leurs gosses
où je fréquente personne quoi mais vite
chez eux
jamais heureusement qu'il ya des gens
dans le coin des amis tout autrement je
suis tout seul tout seul tout ça sur
j'ai autant besoin d'eux que de moi je
crois parce que je peux alors quand même
la rapporter quelque chose sur des
images sur le monde des drogués des
toxicomanes de ces malades qui vivent
dans la came le malheur juste à côté de
nous parmi nous nous aurions pu vous en
montrer bien d'autres encore mais au
bout du compte le chemin de la poudre
lorsque l'on n'en sort pas
lorsque l'on ne décroche pas mène à la
même fin la déchéance physique morale la
mort raul et annie de marseille le
savent
malgré l'héroïne qui les tient ils ont
gardé encore une terrible lucidité
d'autres 1 2
de gâcher notre vie
le dire voilà la nette remontée tient
aussi bien par la prison gérard la
preuve en elle-même bien c'est sûr vous
n'invitez décroche il sera facile et
pourtant je dis rooney ici pas mal de
choses je me retrouve aujourd'hui de
tout rang du temps d'accueil un lourd
passif derrière moi de la prison à des
centres ne pense qu avec une
intoxication puis à d'une certaine façon
à avoir été mis au ban de la société
c'est paradoxal que cela puisse paraître
je faisais partie du corps médical
d'abord ma ma plus permis de
d'exercer le boulot que je faisais moi
parce que ça paraît pour les jazz apparu
parues gros quand même que quelqu'un qui
faisait partie du corps médical prennent
de la drogue
si tu veux un malade peut pas sauver les
gens alors que dans je passe son été
pressé mois peut-être aidé à me sentir
en définitivement jeudi c'est une
supposition mais disons que c'est un
boulot qui me plaisait dans lequel
j'arrive à me retrouver et je peux y la
possibilité de reprendre
jean confirme ainsi mois de plus des
prisons
et comme la parole en beauté
les gens me voient comme le cas mais j'y
mets mes parents parce que mes parents
qui me font vraiment la confiance qui
est qui m'ont jamais laissé tomber qui
ont toujours été là quand j'ai
l'impression quand même qu'ils leur
regard qu'ils portent sur moi a changé
on n'aime point sur l'adour qui fait que
que c'est plus du plaisir pas vrai c'est
plus le plus de plaisir et même la
drogue à la même nous apporte plus ce
qu'on nous donne en effet un suicide à
petit feu mais dont on n'a pas
conscience donc à cette fameuse mondial
avec avec l'héroïne et
le bien-être l'un va sata
la prise de conscience à celui-ci une
fois qu'on aime toxiques etc ont
approché effectivement l'idée du suicide
l'idée que ce suicide à petit feu quoi
bien devient l'expression à mesure c'est
plus utile à petit feu c'est un suicide
à grands pas si j'ai continué à prendre
de la drogue
j'ai pris peur vingtaine d'années c'est
peut-être que j'ai exprimés un mal de
vivre et
si j'en parle maintenant c'est que la
façon que j'ai eue de m'exprimer a pas
été la bonne façon
tu prends aujourd'hui
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est donc pour dire aux gens de
reproduire au jean ii makoun donnait pas
beaucoup le flat-6 quelqu'un qui
souffrent maintenant c'est bien
mais ces deux
pour arriver à vos enfants vos maris
[Musique]